everybody's worried about censorship
it's a real concern it's a real
living breathing concern tyler i know
you work in this space
what do you think about this censorship
that's going on is there like what
happens here ultimately
does this become
what happens in terms of the censorship
game do they win
i think they lose i think it's gonna be
really interesting to see what happens
with elon musk and twitter
um if if elon musk is able to take over
twitter i think you're gonna see a lot
more people
not even conservatives or right-leaning
people but people with money and common
sense who are gonna make moves on these
big companies because
yes rumble's a great platform it's big
but it's not youtube i mean youtube is
massive twitter is massive
you know i tried um
i tried parlor uh i tried oh yeah parlor
too that's right you remind me of that
candace always actually put uh
some something about vaccines she went
to parlor there because she felt like
she didn't know where to put it my guess
is i didn't talk to her personally but
she probably was like i need this in a
in a place where it's not going to be
censored right and i i tried getter i
was we had jason miller in oh got her
yep yeah verified me on getter but i
mean those are echo chambers they're not
twitter is twitter is an echo chamber to
an extent but you still have people that
are speaking out and you i think dc
might be dc draeno might be back on
twitter you're on twitter i mean you
have you have conversations and debates
on twitter
i don't think these other platforms
coming up can never match the size of
those so what i think you're going to
see is a lot more people like elon musk
they're stepping up and making hostile
moves on these companies and
forcing their their will upon these
companies and saying because
yes people say you should repeal um
section 216 was it section 216 right um
but the last thing i think we should do
is have the government get involved
that's right bad idea i think it's on
the
private sector and those who have made
hundreds of millions of dollars like
koch brothers peter thiel you know these
kinds of people to step up
and exert their power and say listen you
don't get to do this this isn't how a
functioning democracy works and you're
seeing people push back on this yeah you
know it's interesting for years i used
to say i worked at fox news so and i'm
grateful for the opportunities i had
there but i was always like where's the
competition
where's the competition like every
industry needs competition you do a
better job when you have comp i don't
care education whatever it may be tv
industry as well i was like where's the
competition now you see newsmax out
there
doing a little better i think they just
have like honestly their whole lineup is
like the old fox lineup it's like
bowling greta manchester and i'm like
whoa
um but
i think it's going to be interesting
where these platforms go i think people
are aware increasingly aware of the
censorship they're pointing it out even
people who aren't in media are like
what's going on here why is why is the i
think the the misinformation campaign
on the vaccine opened a lot of eyes a
lot of parents eyes in particular
because now again it was like
this this this policy about the schools
and the masking this was affecting their
their babies
so they were they eyes were open in ways
that they hadn't been before
silicon valley is powerful big tech is
powerful
and it is i think tyler is right i think
entrepreneurs out there if you can
create a legitimate
the challenge is to create a legitimate
free speech zone
where people of all different opinions
flock to and actually engage
you don't want an echo chamber that's
useless it's useless and it's not fun
and you're not gonna it's not gonna have
longevity because you're not gonna wanna
hang out there
so entrepreneurs out there that's what's
missing is a legitimate thriving free
speech zone where all different opinions
can get involved
but where that act of censorship in one
direction is not happening and isn't
very blatantly transparent i mean it's
honestly ridiculous at this point and
now these memos from libs of tick tock i
think people are just like okay all
right chill
honestly
and i always say you know leave leave
the platform but you know what people
don't want to leave because there are
components on twitter they enjoy i get
it i'm on there there are components
that are really exciting and
fun in small doses remember put the
phone down and get outside every now and
then like i told you yesterday you're
like dad don't tell me what to do just
saying if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]